she was 2 years old she had a first
memory is her dad abusing her mom they
got divorced he left the family and he's
one of these guys out there male enough
to get a girl pregnant but not man
enough to be a daddy so she's raised
with no father she gets to high school
she doesn't know how gentleman to treat
a lady this big football player asks
around they start dating and then he
says her honey I've never felt this way
by a girl before I love you and for her
those words were magic she never heard
that at home and she said why would I
love you too Reuben he said if you love
me show me she know what that means do
you see it
we these women want to be shown do you
see these guys get bamboozled I'm like
no no no no it was not that these evil
men were pressuring her women like women
are sexual too guys women are sexual too
why was she even in that situation to do
that
stuff I mean in High School you you
could be at your parents house or you
could be alone hanging out in like a I
don't know what a car or
whatever Choice choices choices but they
always put it on the men it's always
always always always always always the
men's fault and they're so freaking
annoying and and the thing is guys and
this is my this is my thing to the
men if you are going to prop up your
relationship as the one to be like
it it better be clean otherwise don't
prop it
up you know that that's what I'm saying
otherwise I wouldn't prop it up if I
were you if you're going to go around
calling these guys
degenerates I I would hope you're not
engaging in the degenerate
activity especially when I looked at
Chase's stuff two months
ago like what is crazy people she a
girlfriend cafeteria she said Ruben
wants to start doing this and that what
do you guys think they said you like him
right she was yeah I like him then they
go that's not a big deal everybody's
doing it don't be approved look as long
as you feel ready get it over with so
she figured yeah it's not a big deal at
the age of 15 she lost her virginity
thinking they be forever in love she
said in all actuality all respect was
thrown out the window but she said after
a while he didn't want to spend time
with me anymore he maybe he didn't want
to spend time with you because you
weren't AR Pleasant to be
around everything everything's always
basically spending time with my body cuz
when a girl is getting used she knows it
she tries to distract okay but how is is
it women like to have sex too why isn't
she using
him it's just nothing nothing is the
woman's so she knows there's no peace he
lost respect for her he start fighting
more cuz every time they're together
it's all he wanted and she give him sex
for the sake of feeling love he just
give her love for the sake of sex
eventually they broke up she said I will
never forget the day he walked away for
the very last time she said all I can
think to myself is that guy's leaving
with something that never belonged in
the first place now I'm never going to
get it back not a virgin now the whole
point of waiting for marriage it's too
late for me anyway started to cycle that
was the only honest part he really put
in there you were good at ladies this is
just me being honest it is a tough
sell to ask a guy to wait till marriage
when you were not a
virgin waiting till Mar women we only
want 20% of men so if you're actually
attracted to a guy he's top
20% asking that guy to wait till
marriage when you're not a virgin is a
tough self you're a virgin okay
different rules
fine tough cell tough sell so I mean I I
hope I hope it works out for
you but most men are not going to want
to do that you know
now uh hold on let me pull up the other
ones anyways so again more examples it's
always always always always always hello
hello it's Elizabeth Busby here with a
Theology of wait hold on always always
[Music]
always how she met Jason I mean I can go
on but I mean this is just telling their
love story over and over
again yeah again if the man's asking the
woman to wait then she's entering his
frame and you know I I have no problem
if women want to do that I'm just saying
tough cell tough cell okay and then here
we go always what if somebody goes
through the healing process they do the
heavy lifting then you know they didn't
have the best pass then they find at
somebody and they're starting to look
toward marriage and then you know the
details start to come up about their
past and they want to be honest and
transparent um but the partner the
perspective partner is having a real
rough time with this I I I see this a
lot where one person like I waited and I
thought you'd be waiting for me too and
then now we met and I think you're the
one but I don't know how to process your
stuff like do you ever encounter that
with couples and what kind of advice do
you give them to help them to work
through that as a team yeah all all the
time uh
that's also very common um I think two
things I think on both sides I think for
the one who's sharing the
story uh there a lot of vulnerability in
that and it's like what they want and
need
is to be accepted to be to be uh to have
mercy come back instead of judgment and
so they're looking to feel safe enough
to be able to share it they don't want
to stay in hiding they want to be real
and so there's a you know the person who
okay but there's never a don't accept
that men you don't have to accept
that it's always man up and marry These
Hoes
always always now I've noticed I've
noticed they'll always there's always
like this cope and I started writing
down the
copes okay does that make sense
everybody what I'm saying with the the
gynocentrism in the church this is
Catholic Christians it's in everywhere
and I know because I argue with you
people on
Twitter
um okay let me go down oh so why are men
leaving the church number one the the
quality of wives is not up to par in the
church it's not they go to the church
they see single mothers they see women
with a million red flags and that and
they think well if I'm not going to get
a higher quity quality wife
here where do I go I've also gotten you
know men tell me that the wife or that
church makes their wife work worse
because they have these women's groups
and in these women's groups all they do
is gossip about their husbands and
they're told they're amazing awesome and
special 247 emotional all through his
ministry people were trying to trap
Jesus the Sadducees and the Pharisees
and uh Judas trapped them in the garden
and and and the and the and the the
Roman official get what you'll get in
churches is it's always like a good-look
guy pandering to a bunch of women always
always always always and he probably
does the same thing everyone else does
but he's gonna go on church to look
really cool and build his brand on God
on the cross but Jesus was and then
usually what he'll do is he'll he'll
talk about things in the church and it's
never anything that will make women feel
bad it's only things that'll make them
feel good they'll talk about all the
shortcomings of the husband usband and
never any of the shortcomings of the
wife always always always here we go
does this look like mostly men or
women and this is just me
Googling this was just me
Googling Christian preacher
pastors oh a bunch of
women usually their husbands kind of
like walk like
this
okay um
okay other one and what they'll do is
they'll speak in a very feminine way
they'll
say and they'll just they'll it's soft
and it makes you feel good and God is
coming to save you God is coming to save
you
like and it's never any real substance
and even people that are are not and I'm
just telling you guys I know so many
people that are lukewarm about the
church and the biggest reason they're
lukor is this
hypocrisy and you're playing into it
when you go around calling the red
pillars evil degenerates when you did
the exact same thing two months
ago okay now let's see
um
okay oh you guys got nothing is
burdening you down and you've never
considered the fact that you've already
got what you
need you've been thinking this is not
enough gifting this is not enough Talent
it's not enough money it's not enough
time I don't have enough and Jesus is
whispering in your ear tonight you got
enough we got these female
pastors all talking like this you are
enough you are special you are amazing
you are so important like if I wanted to
be a
pastor that's what you have to
do don't listen to you always need to
have a bad guy right so don't listen to
those evil people over
there you are special and important and
amazing and and God will save you
and that's it boom boom I could it's so
like and I guys I don't know how I how
to describe it but there is something
innate when you can just feel that
someone's full of and a lot of
these pastors they literally think
they're God's chosen one I swear they do
I I they'll tell you that they and they
get such a holier than thou high
horse that
they they don't even see how big of
Hypocrites they are and again if they're
talking about what's a sin and what's
not a sin that's one thing but when you
start saying the evil degenerate red
pillars when your solution is to go to
church and get a
sorry get a born again
home okay sorry I'm sorry guys
okay um let me show you the other one
um
oh I need water but I want to get up
okay all right so I asked the men I
asked the men oh yeah
um now again if we're going to go talk
about hookup culture guys there should
be 10 sermons about women's promiscuity
before there is one on men because the
majority of women partake in can hookup
culture the majority of men do not so
crying about the top 10% of men that get
to screw all the chicks is a waste of
time they're going to do it they have
always done it and 50% of pastors admit
to having emotional Affairs so even if
you're going to sell or sorry emotional
or physical Affairs even if you're going
to sell you're going to say
hey high value men come to our
church they'll say okay what do you have
to offer for me do you have wives well
no we have some okay they'll say all
right um well what do you what do you
have to offer me do you
have are you
gonna are we going to talk about the
things that matter they're like no we're
just going to shame you for sleeping
around they're like okay what what what
did they get from going to the
church what what do they get
now this is is not me hating on religion
this is not me being anti- God they're
trying to paint me as anti-god I'm like
are you people insane you are more
dramatic than these hoes that I've had
on my show the past year oh my gosh
so all because I say hey cheating is
different for men and for women you
should probably just get over it if your
husband
cheats call me crazy
um they're going to say okay if I go to
your church if I go to your
church is it going to be structured
they'll go into the church they'll look
around and they see these concerts they
say
okay what do men what do high value men
get out of following your religion and
before you go around trying to fix the
world's problems maybe try to fix your
own church because most of your churches
are moving in the liberal Direction in
the last 10 20 years I I have not seen a
church that is getting more traditional
and more conservative I haven't seen it
I haven't seen it um even I know people
in traditional catholic communities very
rigid and the way the world's going is
more
liberal
so I I don't make the world that I live
in I'm not saying this is the way I want
it to go but my biggest criticism is
again tradcons will always find a way to
blame everything on the men and you have
bigger problems than 10% of men cheating
there are bigger problems to talk about
so I asked the men um why they left the
church I put this on Twitter feel free
to put your
experience um all right so one
disillusion brought on by breathtaking
Hypocrites the pastor's wife was banging
the youth pastor the junior Pastor was
swapping wives with one of the Elder
tingle Trump's Dogma we are implored to
be
righteous um after a long story to after
a long period of time you realize no one
knows what's going on and the behavior
of the people in the church is usually
in opposite to their beliefs I'm
agnostic but strongly suspect there's an
afterlife or simulation I don't want it
confined to a
religion this isn't the way I want it to
go but this is what happening and I'm
showing you guys why so if you want this
take the Christ pill if you want to do
all this you guys got to fix your
churches before fixing the world and you
guys will go out and you'll evangelize
and preach but nothing will
change until you get successful
competitive men in the church and right
now I look at most churches it's a bunch
of baas that married X hoes and blame
everything on the men always
okay um let me see if there was anything
else I was going to go over um okay like
here this guy Mike
Foster again this is simping this is
absolute sing is a marriage is getting
married to risk yes the danger of
divorcing corrupt family law must not be
downplayed is getting not getting
married to risk yes but the cost of not
having spousal companionship virtuous
sex or
potential Flesh and Blood Legacy might
not must not be
downplayed
okay so I want to tell you guys a
story so I work with a organization that
helps men get access to their children
and that's that's what they mainly do
all they try to do is help men get in
contact with their
kids um and there's a guy at one of
these
organizations um that I work with and he
tells me every month he has men that
kill
themselves
constantly um and one story he told me
was there was a guy
that his wife said that he touched the
children the entire Community thought
that he was a
pedo he lost all of his money
his
legacy his kids were being raised with
an evil woman and he shot himself in the
face he was
found not guilty of
this and um like before anyways it was
in Family Court not criminal court but
his rep reputation was that of one that
touched
children getting zeroed out is not
uncommon it happens a lot it is not a
fringe case that case might be Fringe
but it is not uncommon for a guy to get
zeroed out it is not uncommon for men um
to have their entire reputations
ruined um to lose the access to their
children to have their kids hate
them um so why why don't tradcon say
change the laws first if you really want
traditionalism to come back men will
look at the costs of something and
they'll look at the benefits and right
now the benefits of women are
low you don't get a
virgin they're paid to
leave many have had
abortions many have reinvented them like
the costs the benefits are going lower
and and the costs keep going higher it
becomes riskier and riskier every day
until you fix the system men will stop
getting married regardless of what
anybody puts on
Twitter um let's see if there's another
one I wanted to respond
to you
know when I
started this stuff I didn't know why men
feared
marriage but guys if when you have seen
what I've seen and you have interviewed
the amount of men that I have
interviewed and seen
like I have never seen more and I don't
know how to describe it but it's like
death in a guy's
eyes when his kids are down the street
from him and he can't see them there is
one man
whose ex-wife was dating a
guy that had been convicted of touching
kids and there was nothing he could do
because that guy had already served his
time and he was in the house with his
daughter some of this stuff is hell to
men and the tradcons say oh just wave it
off buckle up get married anyway and
they have no idea what they have they
are talking about go go to Family Court
I don't want to hear about anything
until you guys have actually gone to
Family Court none of them have so go do
it spend a
day you people will not take the Christ
pill until you fix the
system and I do not blame men for
adapting if men can't live without sex
sex is a need for men and they choose to
just screw hose for a lifetime because
they look at that system and say I don't
want to risk my reputation I don't want
to
see I understand that and I I I don't
blame
them and what they'll say is they'll say
the men are are submitting to feminism
most men have normal jobs most men are
not in
politics there are billionaires that
can't fix the system it's not as easy as
just just fix it go fix it there's
people that have been working
50 50 years can't fix the
system it's not that
simple
um and okay I want to
do and the truth of the matter is we are
actually in a post-marriage world
marriage has not existed for 50 plus
years when birth control came in and no
fault divorce we no longer have marriage
you have a system that pays women to
leave that's what you have it's not
marriage and it can't be marriage
because it's only marriage until she
feels like it's
not and what I'll see is I'll see
religious people coping when you say
marriage is
dead they'll find a religious Niche a
very Fringe religious Niche and say well
if only the men prayed every day then
their wife wouldn't leave
them I I saw a study it was from the 70s
and they said couples don't divorce or
maybe 80s if they pray every
day so now the guys have to pray every
day in order to not get divorced every
day can't like take a day
off and they still find a way to blame
it on the men oh if he only prayed
praying will not save you from a scorned
woman no it will not and you need to
warn men about this stuff because many
have no idea what they're signing up
for
okay they'll claim that we're just
making this up I get gas lit oh that's
just your
church I've lived around the world it's
it's consistent across the
world I've lived in different countries
grew up with nannies from around the
world
okay they'll Point po point to their
marriage as the success story which
generally is Born Again virgins
okay generally controlling
wives
generally women that don't follow their
husband it's a happy wife happy life
type
relationship if they do have a virgin
wife what I found is usually there's no
way to verify by that they didn't know
them when they were growing
up I mean so we're really just going
based off of her
word and then what they'll do is they'll
try to make the stats better so they'll
say well first marriages have a lower
divorce rate you're more likely to
succeed in a first
marriage but what they don't do is they
discount that we have a society that
tells on itself with the reputation of
those marriages we have cheaper to
keeper type marriages happy wife happy
life women that publicly berate their
husbands um and they'll try to spin it
as a 75% success rate they don't talk
about the women that get fat they don't
talk about the women
um that nag their husbands constantly
they'll they'll try to sell marriage as
a 50 75% success rate and they also
don't take into account the fact that
many women the women of today are
different than yesterday we have had
social media since we were 12 years old
that affects women we have had a ton of
attention from the time that we were
young and sometimes the tradcons tell on
themselves because they miss the point
women are women regardless of if you go
to another country regardless of if you
go to your church regard like it does
not matter women or women there are some
better some worse but women still have a
nature